the way the cryptos work they are
largely unregulated Market the question
is how much of governance should we see
in this particular space because this is
supposed to be a peer-to-peer
transaction with no third party getting
involved over here but that also brings
an element of risk fraud greed
everything with that over the last
number of years especially this
particular year since the War Began
between Ukraine and Russia we have seen
so much uncertainty breathing into the
market if an investor or a Trader is
worried that they've lost money because
it is sitting with an exchange and now
all of a sudden restrictions being
imposed on withdrawals Whenever there is
a big crisis like the one that we saw
during 2013 the European debt crisis
many of the European governments
actually restricted access to your own
money which is in your bank does that
mean have you lost that money those
restrictions are being imposed because
is governments and Regulators do not
want consumers or public to panic they
want to slow down the little process
because no one has actually that money
sitting in their Banks because Banks
lend that money to other businesses and
entrepreneurs now in the crypto space
with your exchanges which are not
regulated and that creates more concern
at least as service providers that must
be regulated they must come under some
sort of a jurisdiction where they cannot
walk away with people's money so the
moment that we will have it we will see
less worry among investors and trailers
from a fundamental investors perspective
they're only slowing down the process of
withdrawal to stop the Panic or the
bleed that is really taking place in the
market the stock market and Bitcoin both
of them are moving in downward Direction
so that correlation does exist there's
no denial and it shouldn't exist really
because Bitcoin should provide hedge
meaning when stocks are going down we
should see the Improvement just like how
gold at most of the time well we are in
a very different Paradigm where
inflation is that multi-decked high we
have a war on our hand between Ukraine
and Russia we have supply chain issues
we have unresolved issues still about to
hit the market with respect to the
supply chain for soft Commodities and
how that can change into a massive
turmoil in the coming quarters or months
so far from the history since it was
created you know that Bitcoin has been
very volatile and it is a cryptocurrency
which rewards those who have appetite
for holding high risk